WE HAVE BREAKING NEWS.
♪
>> Tucker: THIS IS A FOX
NEWS ALERT FOR YOU.
THE PRESIDENT HAS JUST
RELEASED A MEMO ABOUT
DECLASSIFICATION.
HE SAYS HE WANTS TO RELEASE
INFORMATION ABOUT SPYING ON
HIS CAMPAIGN BACK IN 2016.
FOX NEWS DAVID SPUNT IS
FOLLOWING ALL OF THIS FROM FOR U
FOLLOWING ALL OF THIS FROM FOR S
FROM OUR WASHINGTON BUREAU.
>> WE JUST LEARNED IN THE
LAST FEW MINUTES LITERALLY
JUST RUSHED IN THE STUDIO.
THIS IS THE MEMO FROM THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
I WANT TO READ A STATEMENT
FROM PRESS SECRETARY SARAH
HUCKABEE SANDERS JUST
BRIEFLY GO OVER IT.
SHE SAYS TODAY AT THE AND
RECOMMENDATION OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, PRESIDENT
TRUMP DIRECTED THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY TO
QUICKLY AND FULLY COOPERATE
WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
INVESTIGATION INTO
SURVEILLANCE ACTIVITIES
DURING THE 2016 ELECTION.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS
ALSO BEEN DELEGATED FULL AND
COMPLETE AUTHORITY TO
DECLASSIFY INFORMATION
PERTAINING TO THIS
INVESTIGATION IN ACCORDANCE
WITH LONG ESTABLISHED
STANDARDS FOR HANDLING
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
THIS ACTION WILL ENSURE THAT
ALL AMERICANS LEARN THE
TRUTH ABOUT THE EVENTS THAT
OCCURRED AND THE ACTIONS
THAT WERE TAKEN DURING THE
LAST PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION
AND RESTORE CONFIDENCE IN
OUR PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS.
AGAIN, THIS IS A TWO-PAGE
MEMO.
I'M LOOKING AT IT RIGHT NOW
MEMORANDUM FOR THE SECRETARY
OF STATE.
SECRETARY OF TREASURY, OTHER
CABINET OFFICIALS COMING
FROM PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP.
A STATEMENT COMING FROM
PRESS SECRETARY SARAH
HUCKABEE SANDERS
DECLASSIFYING THAT
INFORMATION ON THE
INTELLIGENCE-RELATED SPYING
INTO THAT 2016 CAMPAIGN
BREAKING RIGHT NOW, TUCKER,
BUT WE WILL BE SURE TO
FOLLOW IT.
>> Tucker: AMAZING STORY.